[Music]
what is up there reject nation thank you
so much for clicking on this video we
are going to start up the series kingdom
right now we don't know anything about
it other than the basic description of
it being a period piece zombie korean
show and i was like hell yeah those are
my three favorite things
korean zombies and old times we did
train to busan the movie reaction easily
when we asked like what else we should
cover easily
kingdom was the most
discussed one there's other selections
too of other movies to to cover that
we'll eventually get to but
uh i was like we've got to give we got
to give the people what they want so
please go ahead hit that like button
also if you could subscribe and click
that notification bell because unlike
covering this every other day we'll
probably just make this weekly just to
keep up with our regular schedule of
everything we do between youtube and
patreon speaking of patreon over there
we got full-length watch alongs where
you sync up with the time code for
kingdom and over there we covered plenty
of shows at the same tier to get
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included thank you to the gentleman over
at prepper for editing down these
highlights for us
let's have some fun people
[Music]
tune in
that just would make me want to look
more
like
keep him alive maybe if he's the emperor
yeah you know like a zombie zomber
like he's not quite dead he probably
still should rule
careful buddy
don't look eyes down my guy
[Music]
legit not what i was expecting
[Music]
king so they don't have emperors
i'm learning
you're gonna end up killing like
everyone yeah you're gonna be
responsible for an outbreak my dude
oh geez
nice
god
it's so paranoid like right off the bat
here
production design on this show is
beautiful
sure that's how crazy just have a zombie
show during this time
[Laughter]
oh
it's a conflicting situation
you know this show's good when it pulls
you into the drama of the situation and
you forget about the whole zombie ankle
she's like damn this guy gonna
catch a break from his mom and rise to
power
will he get the journal
[Music]
how did you lose track of them
stench of the dead
[Music]
my dude plot twist it is due to the
royal contribution
damn
you can't do that [ __ ] can you
i don't know the rules
wow
manipulate like this that's very good
yeah
clearly knows the game
are there pancakes
[Laughter]
is
you
[Applause]
[Music]
that's not positive thinking
[Laughter]
is he stumbling or is he
he looks normal all right yeah i was
gonna say he's gonna fall off this horse
is that a coffin yes and i don't trust
it
it's roped down
the lack of communication on the show so
far
everyone's real good at omitting stuff
it's like a whole character unto itself
damn that the princess
having a bad day but i don't realize
that versus my character like how much
can i really root for this guy yeah it's
like damn this guy's
all kinds of [ __ ]
damn a bunch of [ __ ] man
this kingdom sucks
[Laughter]
can't wait to get out of here
with no beef pancakes
this guy is my favorite character so far
ah okay gotcha
what
nope
the good did you find a deer
she likes it too huh don't
don't
not a finger
oh god
he didn't kill a deer i think my
nightmare is gonna get even worse
everyone's about to turn
sick bastard
um
[Laughter]
hello
oh no
oh she's the first one to transform is
she gonna cough up a toe or something
i know i think she's transforming dude
oh no
oh
oh my god we're going we're going for
where it's happening it's begun
this weekend i thought i thought i'd at
least have another episode yeah
at this rate
oh my god
oh man you doomed everybody
[Laughter]
meanwhile
terrible physician yes
see everyone's dead out there
oh my god
how are we going to explain this
did they invent gunpowder yet
i don't know where exactly we are in
time
no no no no no lady i like you you're
nice though and you're nice
[Music]
you're nice
no lady
no that's the last place you want to put
your hands no no no
yes
careful with your thumbs
all right now only 100 more people to do
this
oh
do you have anything more to say yeah
oh my god
[Music]
wow
oh that is truly horrifying i've never
seen an image quite like that zombie
movie
show
etc
[Music]
tasty not a fun zombie kid
[Music]
oh man now these two gotta work together
oh my god
that was a
flipping fantastic first episode that
was gripping that was
that was
really
truly
that's one of the best something pilots
i've ever seen
wow
that was really good that was wrapped
that was that was amazing that was like
that was really amazing
what a build oh man what a build
his name
you gotta watch the season at least
before declaring but that was that was
incredibly impressive yeah yeah agreeing
off to a solid stuff but for a pilot i
quite loved that it was genuinely
significantly more impressive than i
actually expected it to be
because i heard a period of peace zombie
show and so i kind of just expected like
a crazy zombie show
and yeah
something apt to get to the zombie stuff
and well establish it right off the bat
and then with the opening scene a really
brilliant opening scene to set the stage
for it all like the king is a zombie and
they don't know what zombies are
great use of opening titles and then
contrasting with yeah i feel like
absence being presents throughout the
episode great it was it was really
clever and it but it still set me up for
okay so we're about to like just watch
mayhem right away yeah uh but what this
episode did so clever is it gets you
really invested in the politics of the
situation gets you really invested in
the character because like when i was
what i was impressed with the prince
character was i i found myself
it's instantly went like the did the
establishing shot of him i was like okay
he must be our main protagonist that
we're going to follow
um
i immediately just started getting a
little
semi sent like very semi cynical
underlying semi uh
he's a prince come on he's probably like
spoiled and privileged yeah how much how
much
i'll probably have a problem with this
guy yeah i'm not going to like this guy
dude
and then uh
it's very early on you're like no this
guy's got some real obstacles to
overcome like he might be prince and
title but he's not treated like royalty
and if anything they're trying to shun
him as much as possible right
to the point where they're like now
let's kill him yeah dude's crazy we
gotta kill them yeah you know of course
there's gonna be like names and such and
different factions and clans uh
you know anything like because it's what
i love is that's historical fiction with
a zombie background to it or or zombie
wallpaper that will be overshad that
will be like you know encompassing the
frame throughout
uh
so
just so i completely understand you know
feel free to clarify here because i
don't know like what's
because this is a conversion show i'm
assuming this is korea yeah and then
they were talking about like confucius
which i thought was chinese so did they
marry into a chinese
is that or is that like i'm not sure i
couldn't tell that's what i want just
clarify yeah i don't know enough about
the history either or whether it's like
yeah like confucian scholars and monks
and stuff like you know maybe uh
to the area laid down roots and a lot of
the foundations come from there or what
yeah yeah i'm not enlighten us on the
culture i'm not so caught up in like the
details of understanding because i that
the immediacy of the situation just
makes perfect sense he's he was uh what
i'm understanding he's a bastard child
uh like he was yeah
and
this child the brother is actually born
after
his dad is married yeah so he is
threatened to yeah that totally makes
sense
um
but i it also does put him in a
different shadow and you see how
genuinely caring he is
he seems like he actually does really
care a lot and it was smart to
wait to show that he actually did commit
a form of treason later on but then you
find out the motives and you're like
okay it actually makes a lot of sense
um and then seeing the people who are
like poverty-stricken and very ill
looking at the cultures here and the dr
basically i'm saying the drama and the
characters
was so well fleshed out
and then it's also such great set design
it feel like i don't know if they had
like locations already established and
then they shot there or they built these
sets and i wasn't expecting to walk into
such a period piece
like epic drama like even though it's
only the first episode you could feel
that it's going to get more sprawling in
the way they like you said during the
reaction the way they use space
it shows you like these are really built
and like that when they choose to use
tracking shots to
amplify or intensify a certain dramatic
beat it's really really impressive when
you're like man these are like real
locations you know it's pretty it's
awesome and there's so many and then the
costumes are great
and then you got the the percolating
dread to coin a common john phrase you
got the percolating dread of
the
of the whole zombie horror uh
you know creeping up on us
because like i think that one shot is so
telling of the show when uh the prince
is in the hallway yes they cross front
of the screen door yeah because it's
like and it's like literally they're
lurking in the shadows is an evil
malevolent presence that will soon open
like over
power
the whole kingdom yeah it's really it's
a really telling uh foreshadowing
shot in so many ways and uh
and then of course like yeah i'm gonna
invest in the hierarchy they also have
like some really interesting debates
here
about human life and then the politics
of well so yeah i thought this was
really impressive and the and the zombie
stuff was genuinely scary and it's you
don't often say that with zombie stuff
these days that was genuine
that was genuinely like like that what
i'm saying is the scary stuff came in
the form
of building horror and tension
and letting your mind go places and the
way they handle the reveals where
usually zombie stuff is scary in the
amount of quantity or ferocity
you know yeah not
just
painting the picture
so yeah i was i was genuinely like
kind of dazzled by what we want i
thought i didn't think i would be
that enamored by this all yeah yeah
absolutely i mean i think that is a
great asset at least so far i mean we'll
see how it uh expands but i like that
yeah period piece isn't the wallpaper to
make something zombie more interesting
it's like it seems like it is really
concerned with
diving in and putting you there and i
think there is something that especially
you know in a very saturated genre
especially in the past decade zombie
anything
like setting it in a time before a lot
of technology actually helps to enhance
a lot of what is tense and scary about
this and yeah i loved you you pointed
out like you know all these people are
so you know terrible with lying and
omitting information and and really
manipulating these situations and i love
that there's almost a parallel between
they're literally hiding and concealing
the zombified king but they're also
hiding and concealing all this
information and pretty soon those things
that they keep wanting to maliciously
and opportunistically sweep under rugs
to use to their own advantage are going
to spring forward and break out and
cause
unimaginable havoc
and so yeah i really like that parallel
of and it's not you know uncommon for
zombie
fiction to use
paranoia and you know information or or
you know disinformation
as some kind of metaphor but i think
it's really nicely done here and two you
know then having yeah your different
political uh uh undertones and i'm
curious to see how those expand because
yeah like i'm not an expert on you know
the korean history but i barely even
know american
history lately in life i keep being like
is there like a podcast digest where i
can go back and learn the history of the
world without having to go to like my
high school
uh but yeah yeah yeah i i really enjoyed
the way that they really pull you into
the political intrigue and show you that
that is probably going to figure heavily
in because we don't know what the origin
of this disease is or this you know
paris or whatever's causing this zombie
outbreak but it seems like it is working
to somebody's advantage and then you
have this disparity with these people
who are sort of living in a in like a
you know sick folks camp almost and you
know them
being subject in such a horrible way
like they're so desperate that they eat
this guy and then because of what's been
so concealed and what no one will talk
about because of the few people's
machinations now we have an outbreak
starting and uh yeah it was they did a
really great job of balancing both i'm
like i'm super hooked into just
retention yeah i think it's it's smart
to build that tension of are they gonna
kill the main character for political
gain which is already scary enough the
way they put you into his shoes and then
to have this other situation brewing on
top of it i feel like yeah you really
have a nice
duality of like here's your cool zombie
stuff but also here is an easy way to
ground what the subtext will probably
become well i think what's brilliant
about its setup is it it doesn't feel
like the story lines are in conflict
like
because because of the fact that this is
all stemming from one thing the m the
king he wants to emperor
uh the king and
the king is a zombie yeah
so this is all happening because the
king got zombified yeah and due to that
so that's why it's like you got these
two story lines there yeah so it sets
you up right there political intrigue
and also um zombie show so it's smart
because it doesn't feel like the show's
at odds with itself yeah right from the
top it feels completely blended in and
tight tied to each other and like they
they strike a a really rich tone here
and it
from it's a six episode i think there's
two seasons under six episodes each
and uh
what i love about that especially after
watching this first episode is that
it feels more like a
limited series that they actually threw
money into yes
versus it's gorgeous yeah it feels like
an actual like mini movie or uh i mean
not mini movie but uh
you know what i'm saying mini series
that is something something that that
doesn't have to be encumbered by
uh potentially going indefinitely and
having to stretch the story and maybe
you know pull punches in them like
another couple of
zombie shows out here
i can't imagine which one you're gonna
be talking about i just can't
uh yeah this feels like refreshing and i
was really surprised by how hooked i was
into pretty much every character even if
you're not like emotionally like like
this person i'm at least
like fascinated by the the pool like you
have
god i don't know any other names uh but
though the one guy who's kind of like
the the dude who pins the guy down at
the table he called him the little
finger of the show yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
the guy who's like the head of the cho
clan yes
so with him
uh he's great and i like the prince
character i like the number the the guy
who is like he's like his valet yeah
he's my favorite right now beef pancakes
is great because
yeah i just love like everything he just
addresses like everything could go wrong
are you crazy but i am loyal to you
but because they they it doesn't feel
like he's just uh
the servitude or employee he seems like
he actually is a real friend and he
clearly he likes him to the prince yeah
like willing to stick his neck out for
more than just like i have to because
you're my boss yeah yeah and the the
main lady who's helping taking care of
the people yeah um i don't know i'll try
to remember their names uh
do i do my best to promise i'm going to
do my best
study guide next episode here's the
setting here's everyone's name here's a
chart of faces i i would be curious to
know too uh if you've made it this far
in the video uh
what specific like historical fiction
elements they're dealing with like is
any of this are they are they messing
around with anything that really was
happening at a certain time in history
and i'd be i'm always afraid to do the
research myself because i'm i'm likely
to have something get spoiled for me yes
so
uh yeah but i mean right now like
knowing those things aren't super
important to me uh to to know uh because
right now i'm like i'm still just
gripped into the the immediacy of the
situation like nothing is making me feel
left out despite my
uh uninformed american noggin so yeah i
want to take that opportunity to use the
show as edutainment absolutely right
uh yeah guys this was uh i could see
what everyone recommended this [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] great
uh yo so subscribe click that
notification bell please hit that like
button you can check us on patreon and
uh last but not least let's do up
chris
wham off
i don't know what you're gonna do man
because it's always the nice guy who's
caring for and helping people that gets
bit in the zombie movie three quarters
the way through right when it's gonna
hurt your heart the most you're gonna
sacrifice yourself selflessly but right
before you do what oh your eyes look
different
i don't want that to happen to you chris
so maybe become a little bit more
selfish in this life if there's anything
i learned from watching train to busan
it's only look out for yourself chris
so uh
do that but but but not when it comes to
your patron play look out for us as much
as possible because we're gonna need
that when the grid goes down and all the
mayhem starts but chris
selfish it up
don't die
you know what i would have said what did
you want to say
[Music]